τ κάθως θέλικον πάρα πιστιμίον ανλάζει κάπως το παιχνίδιδο στη αλλάζε το παιχνίδης το ότι
ίδη σε μια θα έλεγα κορεσμένι αγορά το νααρθούν κάποια πανεπιστήμια που έχουν το κύρος
και την αξιοπιστεία που κουβαλούν αυτά τα πανεπιστήμια θα ενταθεί ακόμη περισστοορν ο ανταγωνισμός εντός
κύπρου αλά δεν ξέρω πόσα από τα κάτημαϊκά μα στη δρματα θα παραμείνουν βιώσημα τιθεται
θέμα βιοσιμοτητας θα έλεγα ότι το μεγάλο λάθος ήταν ότι τα πρώτα χρόνια της ραγρίας
άύξεις δεν υπήρ ξε ένα ξεκάθα προ στρατηγικό πλάνο εγώ πάντα λέεω ότι ένα κράτος
πρέπει να καθορίζει που θέλω να πάει αυτός οδομς πώς α πανεπιστεί μια πρέπει να
έχει κύπρος πντε έκα είκοσι τριάντα κανείς δεν μπορεί να πάντησε αυτή στιγμή και θα
έλεγαν δεν είναι μόνο ο αριθμός τον πανεπιστιμίο αλλά τι δεξιότητες και τι εξηδίκευση πρέπει
να έχουν αυτά πανεπιστήμια δεν μπορούμε να κάνουμε όλοι λίγο απόλα ο κάθε το κάθε
α κατμανικόητρημα πρέπει να βρει το δικό του δομέα τα δυνατά του σημί και να
ενδιατρίψεις αυτά τα σημεία δυστιχός αυτό δεν έγινε έμεινε λίγο ανεξέλεκτος ο χάρτης τις ανότερις
εκπαίδευσης υτή στιγμ υπάρχουυ δώδεκαματε μιστήμια ανταβέντες αναντα εξικολέγεια πολύ περισσότερα για να πληθισμό το
ενός εκατομιρίου από άλλες ευρωπαϊκές χώρες και τη δια στγμή προβλέπονται αναμένονται ακόμα μερικά παανεπιστήμετα
επόμενα χρονιάρα πρέπει να δούμε πώς αυτά τα πανεπιστήμια και τα ιδρήματα κατημαικά ητρήματα θα
εμει θα παραμείνουν βιώσημα γιατί είναι δύσκολο να έχει σπιτητές και να έχει στέγματα βιο
σιμότητας για δεν υπάρχει μια εγίς κατάσταση πραγματοτότε δεν μπορείς να έχει κεψη λιπιότητα οι
εργοδότες σήμερα τιψάχον εκείνο που ψάχουν το βρίσκουν μέσα στην κυπρία και αγόρα υψάχνονταις ε
δάλες αγόρεςθα έλεγα ότι ένα από τα μεγάλα προβλήματα είναι αυτό που προσπαθεί τώρα η
κυβέρνεση να κάνει τηδιασύνδεση της αγοράς σε εργασίας με τα κατημαϊκά ιτρήματα για πάρα πολλες
δεκαϊτίες κανείς δε σκευτό τ το μετά έκανας πουδές περδούσαν ωραία εφιτητές ι ακαδημαϊκή προσφεραν
τες γνώσεις τους αλλά κανείς δεν